Dass ihr Bescheid sagt.
Chico muss weg.
Chad muss auch weg.
Claim Drop, Alter.
Das ist so krasser Cheatbait.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es noch nicht mal Drops.
So, die fangen garantiert.
Also wir kennen sie ja schon.
Die fangen mit FIFA an.
Das heißt, wir Residenz lieben jetzt erstmal eine Viertelstunde.
Danach kommt irgendwie Need for Speed
oder irgendwie anderes Residenz-Sleeper-Zeug.
Okay.
Pock.
Es geht los.
Fullscreen.
World Premiere.
Ah ne, das war Xbox.
Muss ich mal gucken, ob laut...
Sag mir mal, ob Lautstärke passt, Leute.
Oh, Toss.
Toss.
Anzeige ist raus, Leute.
Erstmal Musik ausmachen, Alter.
Warum ist da eine Kuh?
Und...
Und ich bin Andy McNamara.
Und ihr schaut das 2021 EA Play Live Pre-Show.
Konzert für Cal.
Was, Pre-Show?
Das wird ein erstes, aber wahrscheinlich mein Lieblings-Weg,
ein Pre-Show zu eröffnen.
Ich will keine Pre-Show.
Die neueste Erweiterung für Sims 4 Cottage Living ist heute raus.
Sims 4 Cottage Living.
Yeah, Mann.
Endlich.
In nur ein paar Minuten kommt das EA Play Live Main Event mit...
Leute, seid ihr auch so gehypt?
... die Überraschungen, die ihr kennt und liebt.
Endlich.
Erstmal wollen wir einen Moment nehmen, um alle zu beurteilen.
All die Neuigkeiten, die dieses Sommer entdeckt wurden.
Und was für ein Sommer es war.
Oh, ja.
Ich persönlich habe nichts anderes getan, als Mass Effect Legendary Edition zu spielen.
Hm, ich denke, du meinst eigentlich Romance Garris oder vielleicht...
Ich bin mir bei denen immer nicht sicher, ob die trollen oder ob die das ernst meinen.
... die Originalen.
Die talentierten...
Ein bisschen leise...
Wir müssen es noch ein bisschen lauter machen.
... die talentierten...
Aber, aber das interessiert mich jetzt nicht, was die erzählen.
Die Trollen nicht?
Das meinen die ernst?
Ich mach dann richtig laut, wenn der Countdown weg ist.
Das ist jetzt Resident Sleeper.
Was bin ich sehend.
Wie viel kostet einmal rollen?
10 Euro.
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz meine Emote Größe anpassen.
Was sehen wir da gerade?
Irgendwie passt die Musik überhaupt nicht dazu.
Das hört sich so nach epischer, keine Ahnung, Herr-der-Ringe-Schlacht an und in Wirklichkeit läuft da ein Würfel mit Beinen.
What the fuck?
Okay, alles klar.
The Chills.
Lost and random, including an exclusive first look at combat gameplay, later on in the main show.
Speaking of combat, I can tell you as a part of the team over at Respawn, that Apex will be showing up later today in a pretty big way.
Of course, Battlefield 22 has some big news to share as well.
Wie ist denn das? Leute, mal eine Frage an euch.
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz hier, EA, muss mal kurz ruhig sein.
Spielt jemand von euch Apex?
Wie schlimm ist dort der Microtransaction?
Microtransaction und Payment-Faktor.
Geht?
Oh nein, FIFA. Gehen wir weg.
Übrigens, übrigens.
FIFA kommt ja immer irgendwie ein halbes Jahr raus, bevor das Jahr anfängt, was es im Namen hat.
Echt okay, Nekorock, dankeschön.
Masch...
Maschinenlernung?
Wozu braucht man genau bei FIFA Maschinenlernung?
Ich glaube, das macht sich einfach nur cool.
Man sagt jetzt zu allem Maschinenlernung und Blockchain.
Ich denke, wir haben jetzt einen goldenen Zeitpunkt, in dem diese Freiheit ermöglicht wird.
Das soll richtig nice sein.
Koop-Game.
Das soll richtig nice sein. Koop-Game.
Ich denke, das ist genau das, weshalb wir in diesen Studios sind.
Denn diese Authentizität ist wert der Schwachheit.
Und sie ist wert der Kampf.
Ihr müsst die Leute fragen, um mit der Idee zu halten und zu bleiben.
Wir sind nicht sicher, was das sein wird.
Und sie werden sagen, weißt du was?
Geh dafür.
Sie geben dir diesen Raum und Raum, um zu spielen.
Es ist so wunderschön und seltsam, den Mann zu sehen.
Jetzt muss er aber hart überlegen, was er sagt, oder?
So nach dem Motto, wir interviewen sie jetzt, sagen sie mal was gutes.
Es ist so beautiful, unique und …
Was erwarten deine Fans von Battlefield 2042 bei EA Play Live?
Ah, Battlefield.
Es ist schon auf der Weichsbühne, seit vielen Jahren und never can happen.
Der sieht voll aus, oder was heißt voll, der sieht ein bisschen aus, finde ich auch, der sieht aus wie einer aus Vikings.
Das habe ich mir schon beim ersten Event gedacht, da habe ich mir gedacht, Alter, der könnte eins, zwei, drei Vikings sein.
Ah, warte mal, ich stelle mal kurz die Kategorie um, ich habe ja noch Just Chatting, geht ja noch gar nicht los,
dann sind wir um Special Events, jawoll.
Oh ja, Sportspiele, endlich, wuhu.
Habt ihr es gesehen hier, AI im Ball.
Ballphysik, Ballkatastrophe.
AI, ist hier Call of Duty, hat es vorgemacht mit der Fisch-KI, FIFA hat jetzt die Ball-KI.
Das ist bestimmt Toss-Musik.
Ich lösche schon mal das Wort, Leute.
Wenn ihr das Wort immer schief haben wollt, Mods, schneidet mit.
Ich lösche das Wort mal, ich weiß nie, was hier Toss-mäßig passiert.
Oh, ist weg.
Battlefield, ja, Battlefield kommt im frühesten 6 Minuten 45.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn es nach mir geht, würden die Battlefield zeigen und dann wäre Ruhe,
weil der Rest von die AI mich wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Okay, Apex können sie noch zeigen.
Ihr wisst, ich bin überhaupt kein Battle Royale Spieler,
aber rein vom Zugucken her und Movement und sowas gefällt mir Apex einfach am besten.
Ich spiele es nicht, aber wenn ich die Auswahl habe, bei was ich zugucke, dann ist es Apex.
Ich bin ein Beast.
Meine Güte, dieses Gelaber.
Egal, Leute, wir müssen durch, keine Chance jetzt.
Wir müssen alles durch.
FIFA won't have news to share in the main show, because we're gonna give it to you right now.
Unbelievable, yes.
Fans of FIFA Ultimate Team already know that this year some fan-favorite footballers are returning in the form of FIFA Ultimate Team Heroes.
Was für ein Ding.
So far and right now.
Oh, 22.
Okay, das ist eine unglückliche Abkürzung irgendwie.
Aber gut.
Was für eine scheiß Abkürzung.
Hast du Titanfall 2 gespielt?
Ja.
Habe ich, ich habe sogar Titanfall 1 gespielt.
Oh, early.
Und wie kriegt man es early?
Weil man Geld bezahlt für es.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Die tun fast so alles.
Schenken sie einem was.
Man muss den Kram kaufen, dass man es bekommt.
Logitech, Polaris, plus tausende Gamecodes und EA Play Memberships.
Ja.
Also macht sicher, dass ihr euch auf die Main Show für eure Chance achtet.
Ich bin nur wegen der Main Show hier.
Ich will euch überhaupt nichts sehen.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Weil ich persönlich einen Handgekodeten Jumpmaster Weapon Charme von Apex Legends habe.
Danke für das.
Ihr könnt es sehr willkommen, wenn ihr es nur durch das Zuschauen der Show auf Twitch erhält.
Also Apex Legends, bleibt dran.
Weil ihr nicht missen wollt, einen näheren Blick auf die neuesten Legenden, die in den Apex Games kommen.
Wenn ihr nicht wisst, über wen ich rede, haben wir unseren ersten Blick auf Seedert.
Ein paar Tage zuvor.
Danke.
wird wie von suno ok hoffentlich fängt gleich an drei minuten ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen
battlefield wird richtig nice eine sache die ich mir schon jahrelang wünsche für wird nicht
nur für battlefield für viele games ich hoffe dass es was taugt am endeffekt also man muss
ja sagen ich habe ja das neue battlefield von dem was man gesehen hat bisher immer gelobt ich muss
jetzt aber mal eine sache klarstellen ja ich finde das cool was man sieht das cool was man
bisher also was man so gezeigt bekommen hat dass das game am endeffekt was taugt das will ich damit
gar nicht sagen das kann so geil aussehen und wenn es am ende raus kommt spielt sich kacke das
weiß man ja nicht ja das war apex
trailer
wenn krempa sah uns uns sehen senkowski meiste kommt also die maßnahmen springe ich in die luft
salomon 95 ich darf noch nichts sagen aber was ich sagen kann glaube ich ist du liegst nicht so weit
daneben aber was genau gibt es nicht
formel 1 okay wir haben noch nicht gibt leute wir haben noch nicht genug resident
sleep hat jetzt kommt noch formel 1
jawohl wir machen jetzt ja ja ja racing
musik moment aus musik musik
musik
ausmusik bestimmt aus musik als trotz musik heutzutage weißt du nie ich bräuchte irgendwas
zum über zum zum überspielen so hier was das passt doch mario kart musik es glaube ich gar
kein mario kart excellent gleich viel besser okay 35 sekunden gleich geht's los als nächstes mal
struktur
super tux karte also overlay ja okay auf geht's so leute sagt sagt und jetzt
ein stückchen lauter es schreckt mich nicht so was für schreiter da einfach jetzt rum
wer
natürlich hat bestimmt super schwere controller die erhält für die oberarme
kannst du den stream laut da machen wir es doch übelst laut wobei das recht
so ist gut
Es hat jetzt erst angefangen.
Resident Sleeper Sport Games.
Please.
Was geht mit ihm eigentlich gerade ab?
Wie sie immer so auf Fake-Hype machen, Alter.
Oh ne, jetzt kommen Sport Games.
Oh nein, Sportspiele und Rennspiele.
Ist das Toss-Musik?
Das ist bestimmt Toss.
Ist das Toss-Musik, Leute?
Ist das safe?
Na, wenn ihr sagt, dass das safe ist.
Ich mache aber ein bisschen leiser.
Ich finde, die Musik ist gut.
Ich finde die Musik echt ätzend.
Battlefield zeigen die vor Apex,
damit die Apex-Leute warten.
Das kann durchaus sein.
Übrigens, dass die Musik so übersteuert ist,
das liegt nicht an mir.
Das gehört dazu.
Ich habe leiser gemacht.
Weil es mir zu laut ist.
Beziehungsweise zu anstrengend laut.
Und...
Okay.
... ist Codemasters Senior Game Designer,
Becky Crossdale.
Welcome, Becky.
Hey, Austin.
Hey.
Now, I heard that you might have a little surprise for us today.
Yes, I do.
And I don't know if you can tell, Austin,
but I am so excited.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Sie ist so excited.
... Codemasters Team.
This is a world premiere trailer
for Grid Legends.
Es ist noch nie vorgekommen,
dass jemand excited war auf solchen Shows.
Das ist das erste Mal.
World Premiere.
Excitement.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen,
ich weiß nicht, wer das ist,
aber es interessiert mich auch null für Rennsport.
Monka Stier.
... to win.
Touring Cars.
Muscle Cars.
Open Wheel.
Drift.
Best Team.
Best Car.
Win by having the money,
by having the guts.
These idiots can't keep their cars on the track.
Leute, ich hoffe, ihr seid auch so excited.
People, you cannot stop.
You're gonna get somebody hurt.
Hopefully, it'll be you.
But we're here.
We need Monka Stier as an E-Mode, right?
Ich glaube, wir brauchen dringend Monka Stier als E-Mode, oder?
Moment, Moment, Leute.
Ich brauche... Moment.
Ich muss dringend Monka... Monka Stier...
Becky, das sieht unglaublich aus.
Auf der Bühne des Spiels und der Autos und der Umgebung.
Jetzt haben wir alle diese Charaktere,
die verschiedene Motivationen haben.
Ich bin schon sehr investiert.
Es sieht so aus, als ob ihr euch wirklich
auf die Anni auf Storytelling einstellt.
Nun, vormittig ist die Serie von Grid
immer die Aufgabe, Gameplay-Exzellenz zu erzeugen.
Und mit Grid Legends...
bekommt ihr immer noch die gleiche
immersive Renn-Experienz, die ihr kennt und liebt.
Aber dieses Mal nehmen wir die Dinge ein bisschen höher.
Und wir geben noch einen Teil dazu.
Wir sind wirklich stolz auf diese neue Story-Mode.
Ich liebe eine gute Geschichte.
Und ich glaube, ich habe schon viele solcher Spiele gesehen.
Ja, wir hatten das absolute Vergnügen,
mit dem unglaublich talentierten Shuti Gatwar zu arbeiten,
der den wunderschönen Eric in Netflix' Sex-Education spielt.
Wir haben auch das gesamte Spiel gefilmt.
Was?
Das ganze mit Extended Reality, oder XR.
Wenn ihr Disney's The Mandalorian gesehen habt,
dann habt ihr das in Aktion gesehen.
Es ist das, was diese unglaublichen Welten erschaffen hat.
Das klingt großartig.
Aber das ist nicht Renn-Spiel im Raum, oder?
Nein.
Wir nutzen diese Technik, um euch weiter in die Renn-Experienz zu führen.
Wir wollen euch wirklich tiefer in den Grid-Welt bringen
als bisher.
Es ist auch wirklich großartig für unsere Schauspieler,
weil sie an etwas kämpfen,
against something that's visually there it's not the same as green screen or motion capture they
are stepping into our great world and reacting with it it sounds great can you give us any
hints on the story or that be spoilers without any spoilers we are giving a classic underdog
tale we will put you straight into the driver's seat right in the middle of the great world series
ich hätte den vorschlag man könnte anstatt krasse experience und excitement ein gutes game machen
elektroautos
legends ist ein äußerst ausgelutschter titel oder
modus
die
city of moscow
or you could travel to the stunning strada alpina and take one of our beautiful hyper cars to its
limit
new locations this is beyond exciting so becky thank you so much for legends thank you austin
leute wartet mal heute ab ihr liegt näher dran als ihr denkt
two years ago apex legends came out of nowhere and now 100 million players and 17 legends later
it just keeps getting bigger
we've got more modes more maps more plans for
apex or just for legends so what's the next for apex
you have answers lady and gentlemen i give to you
apex legends emergency fifa okay fifa ich sag mal für games wo ich mich interessiere
fifa kein schimmer nein nein mehr als fifa bestimmt nicht jackie i see it in everything
apex
Das neue Helden-Teaser? Moment, wie heißen die, wie heißen die in Apex? Operators, Specialists, Helden, äh, Pilots, Legends, ach Legends, ach die heißt einfach Legends.
Hi-Fat-Time, Alter. Hi-Fat-Time. Ich meine, die haben mit Apex über eine Milliarde schon verdient, müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen. Oder Billion, wie die Amis sagen. Ist das Blade? Ne. Machen die eigentlich auch Crossovers wie Fortnite?
Ne.
For this chaos has purpose. All of us thrown together, so the flame can burn its brightness. Change, fight it, and fall.
Schreckt.
Ja, Alter. Ist gut, ist gut.
Huge acting.
Chat?
Cute? Chat?
Ach, ach so, Chat.
Alright, well, a subset of them.
If you love Apex, it's because of these amazing developers that are working hard creating Apex Legends for us.
Haha, well, big love to the whole team.
The whole Respawn team, especially whoever came up with Lifeline, cause that's my girl.
But okay, there's a lot for us to talk about, but you know I'm geeked about Seer, so can you tell us some more about the capabilities?
I saw this man staring at walls, he's got drones coming out of his chest. Please tell me about his kit.
Yeah, similar to Bloodhound, Seer is all about tracking enemies, but in a different way and has a very unique kit.
So, while you're aiming down the sights, you'll have a heartbeat sensor that will give you hands as to where an enemy is.
Oh.
If you think you've located them, you can use your tactical, which sends out some of those drones out of your chest and will actually reveal and track the enemy's location.
The ultimate is really powerful, especially in 3D gameplay situations, you can send out hundreds of micro drones and create a sphere around an area that you choose and all enemies that are moving quickly through that space are tracked.
I love when there's new abilities that kind of change the game.
Cause this game obviously is always changing.
Always evolving.
And whenever there's a new legend, there's always an interesting shift in the meta.
Es gibt eine Sache, die nicht OP ist.
So, with those incredible abilities, how do you think that Seer is going to change the game?
Yeah, again, I mentioned Bloodhound also as a tracker, but unlike Bloodhound, Seer is about very precise and lingering information.
So, he's a bit more of a stealth-oriented legend.
Stell so.
And you're gonna see, I think, some interactions because of that sphere I mentioned, his ultimate.
If you're moving quickly through that space, your footsteps are revealed.
But now if you're walking slowly, you can avoid the detection.
And so I think you'll see some interesting gameplay experiences and new ways to play with slowing it down a bit.
Yeah, it sounds like once the ring gets tight especially, you're gonna have a lot of new ways to play this game.
But this past season, for instance, it feels like Apex really moved beyond Battle Royale with the introduction of Arena.
So, what's the reaction been like for you guys?
The fan reaction has been really great.
We've seen a lot of players enjoy Arenas, which is awesome.
We're really excited to finally have a way to play Apex Legends beyond Battle Royale.
And yeah, people love it.
So we've got new maps in the works.
And some other things come in I don't want to talk about just yet.
But we've got a lot planned for Arenas.
Alright, fair, fair.
Well, I do know that you guys announced ranked Arenas are coming as well.
So can you give us some information on that?
Yep, so we've got one season of Arenas under our belts now.
We wanted to make sure that we were seeing how players were adapting to the mode.
Make sure to get the...
We're really excited in September to be coming out in the year two of ALGS.
And for the first time, we're gonna be inviting PlayStation and Xbox players to compete alongside the PC players.
Really see who's best and an all-new league format.
So we have more information at playapex.com slash ALGS.
Well, I am beyond looking forward to it.
And Chad, before you go, I have to ask.
When can we see more from Seer?
We've got an awesome gameplay trailer coming on Monday.
And emergence drops on August 3rd.
And for now, I can show you a finisher.
Of course, please, please.
Finish uns mal.
Und danach Battlefield, Leute.
Hoffe ich mal.
Sieht aus wie Junkress.
Sieh du mal.
Ja, that's all I need to see.
It's just that so awesome.
But Chad, thank you so much for being here.
Thanks Austin.
Habt ihr gesehen?
Kekonadatum.
Now for the Apex fans watching us on Twitch today.
0726.
Respawn is hooking you up with an exclusive jumpmaster gun charm.
So make sure you got your Twitch and EA account linked.
And keep watching the show to earn that drop.
But that's not the only thing.
Ich habe gedacht, sie gehen nach Schwalbe.
Aber erst mal kommt was anderes.
Die machen Battlefield zum Schluss, dass man dabei bleibt.
Der Sprecher kommt mir bekannt vor.
Wer ist der Sprecher?
Ja, mehr gestellte Show, please.
Und es kommt bald.
Zu uns von Gothenburg, Schweden, um uns mehr zu erzählen, ist Zoink-Kreativ-Direktor Olav Redmo.
Hallo, Austin.
Wie geht's, Olav? Danke, dass du uns beitragst.
Und Glückwunsch an Tribeca.
Es ist so cool, Videospiele neben Filmen zu sehen, die so bezeichnet werden, wie sie sein sollten.
Danke, Austin. Ich bin so stolz auf das Team von Zoink und auf das, was wir erreicht haben.
Und ich bin so froh über die Wahl, weil Lost in Random wirklich inspiriert ist.
Mit all diesen Filmen, mit denen ich geboren bin, und Stop-Motion-Animationen und dunklen Feiertagen.
Und bei Zoink versuchen wir immer, die Narrative in Videospielen zu steigern.
Also bin ich so glücklich.
Ich kann nicht warten, mehr zu sehen, Olav, von meinem Leben.
Was hast du für uns heute?
Ich bin super glücklich, einen ersten Blick auf einen unserer wichtigsten Aspekte des Rallye-Spiels zu sehen.
Die Dice-Battle.
Die exklusive Blende von Real-Time-Aktionen und Zeit-Stopp-Taktiken.
Wo jede Rolle der Dice unglaubliche Kraft überlebt.
Überlebt es wenigstens nicht so.
Wir sind Jack-in-the-Box-Buddy Dicey.
Das klingt großartig.
Also, lasst uns mal schauen.
Einmal war es so, dass es zwei gewöhnliche Brüder gaben, die Even und Ord genannt haben.
Kruell von einer bösen Königin.
Und die Rolle der Dice...
Das haben wir doch gerade schon mal gesehen.
Was meint ihr eigentlich? Wie gut Würfel rollen mit Beinen?
Eben wurde sie einfach ermutigt, ihre verehrte Schwester zu retten.
In diesem komprechen und faszinierenden Weltraum von Abenteuer und Kampf.
Und viele witzige Charaktere warten auf sie.
Die beste Überleitung wäre, wenn sie jetzt sagen würden, von Dicey weiter zu Schweden zu Dice oder sowas.
Das wäre Big-Brain-Überleitung.
messe pfeifert
das
Das ist so eine Mischung aus Adventure und Deck-Bilder oder sowas?
Und jetzt kostet es erst mal 5 Euro im Shop. Sonst geht's game nicht weiter.
Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Wenn die noch einmal Dicey sagen.
Okay, ich wollte gerade sagen, jetzt muss ich mir irgendwas ausdenken, was ich sage.
Ist zum Glück, zum Glück hat sich erledigt.
Ja, ich finde Karten klingt ja schon mal hart nach Dice Battle.
Ja.
Merkt ihr doch Dice.
Fuck you, Last Stand.
Und das ist nur ein Geschmack. Es gibt viele verschiedene Kräfte an deiner Hand.
Einige schlagen Feinde an, andere heben sich oder erzeugen Träume.
Einige Arenas funktionieren auch als riesige Boardgames, die von Rolling Dicey betroffen sind.
Du wirst also verschiedene Taktiken versuchen, um den König der riesigen, verrückten, tabletop-themed Arenas zu überwinden.
Okay, Olaf. Natürlich meine nächste Frage. Du weißt, dass es kommt. Wann können wir dieses Spiel spielen?
Ja, meine Lieblingsfrage.
Lost in Random wird am 10. September auf PC, Konsole und Nintendo Switch veröffentlicht.
Du kannst es direkt nach dem Spiel pre-ordern.
Und wenn du einen eigenen Dicey-Anhänger möchtest,
wird er für die EA-Play-Mitglieder als Gun-Charme in einem meiner aktuellen Favoriten, Apex, erhältlich sein.
Also schau dir das an.
Nun, ihr habt es alle zuerst gehört.
Und Olaf, vielen Dank, dass du uns heute mitgebracht hast.
Es war mir ein absoluter Freude, Austin, und willkommen bei Random.
Danke.
Dicey-Anhänger, ja.
Los geht's.
Lost in Random kommt bald, aber es gibt noch einen EA-Original, der bereits hier ist.
Und er bringt das Spielfeld-Heat zu den Massen.
Das stimmt.
Ich spreche von Knockout City.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, okay.
Ich dachte, es kommt Battlefield.
Aber, nein.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wuhu!
Gestoppt dieses Jahr.
Knockout City hat einen verdammten Sommer.
Und die Leute sind gerade aufgewärmt.
Hier mit mehr ist Karthik Bala von Velen Studios in New York.
Danke, Austin.
Wir sind so dankbar für unsere Gemeinschaft,
für die massive Reaktion zu Knockout City.
Mit Millionen von neuen Brawlers,
Hunderten von Tausenden von Crews
und fast ein Billion KOs sind gelandet.
Deine Reaktion war wirklich ein Knockout.
Okay, ich hab noch nie was davon gehört.
Haben alle von euch dieses unikale Ding genutzt,
ist ein großartiges Gefühl.
Und ich möchte nur sagen, danke.
Am Anfang haben wir euch neue Features und Updates versprochen,
die das Spiel frisch und aufregend halten.
Heute bin ich hier, um das Versprechen anzunehmen.
Auf behalf des gesamten Velen Studios Teams
ist es mein absoluter Vergnügen,
Knockout City S2 zu präsentieren.
Kämpfe bei den Filmen.
In einem Weltraum des Chaos,
in dem Mayhem die Straßen regiert.
Ist jemand stark genug,
um die Unabhängigkeit zu stoppen?
Ein Weltraum, in dem ein Helikopter wächst,
in dem die Welt sofort verletzt wird.
Oh, ist ja massive beliebt.
Wo Liebhaber ihre Leidenschaften fressen
und den Schmerz fühlen.
Ein Weltraum, in dem der Schmerz
hoch ist, wo die Wunder kämpfen.
Wo Dodge Brawler
die Krise übernehmen.
Und Teen Z, kleine Brawler,
kämpfen in einem Schatz.
Ich meine, hey,
ich wollte gerade sagen,
Steam ist nicht das Einzige,
Steam ist nicht das Einzige
und 613 Player,
Peak ist mehr als die meisten Spiele auf Steam haben.
Fairness halber, ja.
Oh man,
that voice is murder on the pipes.
The Hollywood Drive-In opens July 27th.
We'll see you at the movie.
It's showtime.
Mhm, you saw it.
We got new skins,
we got a new ball.
Knockout City, baby.
Season 2 arrives July 27th.
Das Acting von dem Typ ist einfach so real.
Ich kaufe ihm jede Emotion ab.
So get in.
You might come across me and my crew.
We're called that baseline.
You won't beat us,
because we're really good,
but you'll have fun.
And right now,
it's available on all platforms
with crossplay.
So if you haven't yet,
go ahead, get in there
and give it a whirl.
Alright, everyone.
The moment that you have been waiting for is here.
Oh!
You've seen the trailers.
You've read the hot takes.
Endlich.
You already know that Battlefield is back, baby.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was ihr sagt.
Battlefield is back, baby.
It's Battlefield.
I can't wait to win.
Es wird wild.
This game is gonna be so good.
Was, lauter?
And in just a moment,
we're revealing a brand new Battlefield 2.
We're revealing a brand new Battlefield 2.
and a 2042 experience.
or lauter, Leute.
Ich mal eins lauter noch!
Okay.
Jetzt aber, jetzt reicht's.
Jetzt reicht's aber!
Oh nein!
Ich-
ich mein, ich war auch gehypt,
als ich das gesehen hab.
Aber diese Reactions jetzt.
Na gut, okay.
Warum nicht?
Ich komm her. Ja, ich war da auch drin. Habt ihr mich nicht gesehen. Der Wikinger ist back.
Pass auf.
Dice L.A. ist das Danger Closed gewesen. Ich werf die vielleicht noch durcheinander.
Battlefield Ultimate Team. Es ist kein Battle Royale.
Habt ihr Caspian Border gesehen? Habt ihr Valparaiso gesehen?
Ja.
Habt ihr die Battlefield Bad Company 2 Granate gesehen?
By the way, soll ich euch mal was sagen? Dieses ganze Battlefield Trailer Zeug würde
viel geiler ankommen mit dem Battlefield Team unten drunter. Ich find sogar den Namen mal ganz
gut. Es ist aber wahrscheinlich nicht das, was ihr denkt. Wartet mal
ab. Wartet mal ab. Wartet mal ab, Leute.
Hey Austin, thanks for having me. Super excited to be here.
Yes, wer hat das gedacht? Super excited.
Wie wollen sie das balancen? Wart mal ab. Wart mal ab.
It's a new community driven experience that gives players a chance to be a part of a community.
It's a new community driven experience that gives players the freedom to write their own
rules and shape their own battlefield. You can mix and match content from Battlefield
1942, Bad Company 2, BF3 and Battlefield 2042 to create brand new game modes. Then you can
share and discover those on the portal. Also auf gut Deutsch, es ist ein Level-Editor.
And that's just what's coming at launch. This is a real love letter to the fans from
our incredible team. And oh, and this is your squad. Yes, this is the fantastic RippleEffect
team. And they deserve all the credit in the world for creating this great experience.
We've had so much fun bringing back some of the most beloved vehicles, gadgets...
Besser als Halo Forged, besser als Halo Forged. Wart mal ab, bis sie es zeigen. Ich darf noch
nix erzählen.
Well, thank you all. Huge, huge credit to this amazing team and everyone, who's made
Battlefield 2042 possible.
Alright, so, to bring it back. When you say beloved maps, we're talking Caspian Border?
Yes.
...Arica Harbor?
Al-Alamein?
Yes. Al-Alamein?
Ich wette mit dir, ich wette mit dir, er hat keines dieser Maps je selbst gespielt.
Ja, das wollte ich euch zeigen.
Das ist nicht...
Wie der Halo-Level-Adder, du kannst wirklich Logik programmieren drin.
Wie ein Schottis-Sniper, wie ein Schottis-Sniper-Gang mit einigen Schottis-Snipern aus der Geschichte.
Das ist eine sehr spezifische Idee, Austin, aber ja, du kannst das.
Batten 3 für 3, bring es nach Hause. Kann ich als ein Pinguin mit einem Flamethrower spielen?
Ein Pinguin mit einem Flamethrower?
Ja.
Nein, ich meine, es gibt einige Grenzen. Es ist kein Level-Adder, du kannst die Maps selbst editen.
Und nein, du kannst als ein Pinguin mit einem Flamethrower spielen.
Okay, das ist gut.
Das ist gut, ich musste fragen.
Aber es klingt so, als gäbe es eine Menge zu spielen.
Oh ja, die Optionen sind ziemlich tief und wir sind engagiert, mit der Gemeinschaft zu arbeiten, um diese Säule von Geräten und Inhalten zu bauen, als das Spiel sich entwickelt.
Wir wollen, dass diese Erfahrung dort ist, wo du es willst.
Wir sehen diese Sandbox als eine große Teil der Zukunft von Battlefield 2042.
Ich hoffe wirklich, dass die Spieler Portal beherrschen werden.
Das ist, wofür wir es gebaut haben.
Es ist nur ein Logik-Editor anscheinend.
Ich dachte aber, es ist ein Level-Editor.
Oh, okay, ich dachte, meine Invitation wurde in der Mail verloren, aber das ist in Ordnung, das ist in Ordnung.
Schauen wir es uns an.
Zwei Teams und zwei VIPs, aber nur ein Weg nach der Schule.
Das ist ein VIP-Fiesta von Courage.
Oder nur halb aufgepasst.
Und ich habe diesen Logik-Editor gesehen und habe direkt gedacht, es muss ein Level-Editor sein.
Facing off on Araka Harbor with 24 players and random loadings.
Du wirst sterben, und du wirst wieder mit einem neuen Loadout deployen.
Tracke den Vip-Enterteil runter und mach ihn zählen.
Oder bringe die Macht von 2042 an die Kaspian-Border und nimm die Macht von 1942 an.
Das ist Qualität gegen Qualität von Gabitron.
Ein kleiner Squad von 2042 nimmt 32 Spieler von 1942 an.
Die Zukunft hat die Hardware.
Aber die Vergangenheit hat die Zahlen.
Zerstöre diese M-Comps.
Das wird man wahrscheinlich mit Bots spielen können.
Gehe ich mal stark von aus.
Memes?
Gut.
Set up on orbital for the fight of your lives.
With Robotman by Redacted.
20 duck-sized EOD-Bots.
One horse-sized T-91.
Set up your battlefield deployment.
Base on who wins what.
Come on, dude. Robotman, what?
This looks so much fun, but I need to know.
Just me and you.
Who's Redacted?
Can't tell you that, sorry.
But what I can tell you is that we're so excited for the players to create or simply discover their favorite new way to play Battlefield.
And we can't wait to explore and try out the thousands of experiences our community will build once they have the tools in their hands.
And we get our hands on Portal at launch, right?
Yes.
Portal will be available at launch, day one, along with a bunch of pre-made modes for you to try right away.
Okay, this is fantastic.
Christian, before you go, let me make sure that I have all of this straight.
So on top of all the content and maps that have already been announced, we also get content from Battlefield 1942, Bad Company 2 and Battlefield 3.
So we have all the content and maps that have already been announced.
We also get content from Battlefield 1942, Bad Company 2 and Battlefield 3.
And we also have content from Battlefield 2 and Battlefield 3.
So we have all the content and maps that have already been announced.
And we also get content from Battlefield 2 and Battlefield 3.
Including six of the best maps of all time.
And all that can be sliced, diced, mixed together, and opened.
And then we still have Hazard Zone coming later this year?
Yes, that's exactly what I'm telling you, Austin.
Ich dachte eigentlich selbst, es ist ein Level-Editor.
Ich will da nicht rein.
Dead Space?
Vom Sound und der Optik?
Es hört sich stark nach Dead Space an.
Ah, FIFA, okay, sorry.
Dead Space, muss Dead Space sein.
Dead Space Mobile.
Das ist das Raumschiff aus dem ersten Teil.
Ist das ein Remake?
Oder was ist das jetzt?
Also wenn das ein Remake ist, dann sage ich euch mal ganz ehrlich,
ist das ein Remake, das die Welt nicht bringt.
Das ist ein Remake, das die Welt nicht braucht.
Dead Space 1 sieht immer noch top aus.
Das ist jetzt fertig, ja.
Also wenn das wirklich ein Remake ist, dann braucht es die Welt wirklich nicht.
Macht das noch was?
Der Code war It's Back, ja.
So, mal kurz gucken, ob ich das Asset Pack jetzt öffnen kann,
dass wir uns das Battlefield-Ding nochmal angucken können.
Asset Pack, hier.
Hoppy, hier.
Schaffen wir nicht aufmachen, erst in vier Minuten, Leute.
Erst in vier Minuten darf ich es öffnen.
Monka S.
So, genau.
Sonst kommt die Feuerwehr.
Ich glaube, das war's, Leute.
Ich glaube, da kommt nichts mehr jetzt.
Jetzt ist es ein bisschen leise und wir sind ein bisschen gedudelt.
Ja, ich muss sagen, mich hat nichts geschockt außer Battlefield.
Und selbst das wusste ich schon.
Und ich habe mich auch noch vertan, Leute.
Ich dachte, der Desktop, der ist richtig gut so.
Ich habe gedacht, es ist ein Level-Editor.
Aber ich muss zu meiner Verteidigung sagen,
ich habe...
Genau zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo die Ankündigung war
und wo die uns das gezeigt haben,
versucht die New World Beta zu installieren
und Charakter zu erstellen, damit ich reinkomme.
Das heißt, ich habe nur auf dem zweiten Bildschirm ein bisschen zugeguckt
und das, was ich gesehen habe, war dieser Logic-Editor
und ich habe instant gedacht, das muss ein Level-Editor sein.
Weißt du, was eine Public Beta ist?
Ja, gucken wir mal in das Asset Pack, ob da irgendwas drinsteht.
Sie haben was gesagt, ja.
Aber Public weiß ich nicht.
Public weiß ich nicht.
Wir müssen noch zwei Minuten warten, Leute.
Wo kann man den Code eingeben?
Keine Ahnung.
Haben wir jetzt eigentlich noch was?
Nee.
Thanks for watching.
Jetzt fertig.
Äh, RIP.
Okay, ich glaube, für die Leute, die Apex spielen, war was Gutes dabei.
Für die Battlefield-Leute war auch was dabei.
Dieses Adventure-Game.
Okay, muss man mal gucken.
Dieses komische Wir-werfen-uns-mit-den-Ball-ab-Game hat mich überhaupt nicht gejuckt.
Ja gut, und Rennspiele und FIFA jucken mich ja prinzipiell nicht.
Chat aktivieren, jawohl.
Wir machen den Chat wieder rein.
Und Chico. Chico muss auch wieder rein. Perfekt.
Leute, noch 50 Sekunden, dann darf ich es euch zeigen.
Wir können es ja schon mal entpacken.
Alter, wie groß ist denn das?
Wie groß ist das denn? Was ist denn da alles drin?
Okay.
Das ist 1,16 Gigabyte.
Wie sehr muss DICE getriggert sein, dass es vorhin geleakt wurde?
Was wurde denn geleakt?
Dass es Battlefield Portal heißen wird, oder was?
Wurde das geleakt?
Achso, das wusste ich gar nicht.
Einer hat auf die NDA geschissen.
Ja, gibt immer so was.
So, es ist 20 Uhr, jetzt darf ich es euch zeigen.
Also, Community-Gameplay-Videos.
Was gibt es da?
Zeig her, Community-Gameplay-Videos.
Was haben wir da drin zu bieten?
Ich habe mir das noch nicht angeschaut.
Ich habe es mir noch nicht angeguckt, Leute.
Okay, das haben wir schon gesehen.
Das ist das gleiche, was wir gerade schon gesehen haben.
Okay, nichts Neues.
Wahrscheinlich sind im ganzen Asset-Pack nichts Neues.
Lul.
Aber gut, das ist ja auch ein Asset-Pack.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass was...
Okay, da stehen nur noch mal die NDAs und sowas drin.
Infographic.
Also, was haben wir hier?
Also, was ist im Portal dabei?
Es gibt Content aus 1942, Bad Company 2, Battlefield 3.
Gut.
Ehrlich gesagt, Leute.
Ich habe echt gedacht, das ist...
Also, ich habe an einem Stream, wo ich...
Wie gesagt, ich habe es nur auf dem zweiten Bildschirm geguckt.
Ich habe das da gesehen und habe gesagt...
Cool, ein Map-Editor mit so einem...
Wie heißt das bei Unreal?
So eine Art Blue-Box-Geschichte.
Oder ne, Blue-Print-Geschichte.
So Logic-Blocks.
Das ist für die Noobs, die nicht programmieren können und lieber Blöcke zusammenstöpseln.
Habe ich gedacht, ey, das muss ein Level sein.
Ist das aber gar nicht.
Da habe ich mich vertan.
Also, es gibt keine wirklichen Mods in Form von neuen Maps oder stark veränderten Maps.
Es gibt halt einen Spielmodus-Editor.
Das ist aber auch schon mal cool im Vergleich zu dem, dass du in der Vergangenheit nichts machen kannst.
Wobei ich mich halt echt frage...
Also, wie soll ich sagen?
Das täuscht ja nicht darüber hinweg.
Also, sollen wir mal davon ausgehen...
Also, wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen würden...
Die hätten halt kein Content für Battlefield 2042.
Dann kann man damit auch nicht darüber hinweg täuschen.
Zusätzlich ist es natürlich geil.
Ach ja, übrigens, was ich euch auch erzählen darf.
Das muss man nicht ingame machen.
Es gibt so eine Art Web-IDE dafür.
Ich nenne es mal IDE.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie es aussehen wird.
Es gibt so eine Art Web-Editor dafür.
Man muss es nicht ingame machen.
Also sprich, man kann es wenigstens ordentlich bedienen.
Hoffe ich mal.
Ich nenne es mal IDE.
Ja, ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Editor im Web.
Logo.
Screenshots.
Okay, das Asset Pack kann man sich im Prinzip auch sparen.
Es ist halt ein grafisch schönes Waldparaiso.
Ein schickes Caspian Border.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal als alte Hackermans mal an, was wir hier sehen.
Also als erstes brauche ich ein WIM-Plugin.
Genau, ohne WIM-Plugin tut sich hier schon mal gar nichts.
Ganz ehrlich, mir ist einfach Source Code lieber.
Was bin ich hier überhaupt sehend gerade?
Es ist im Prinzip leer.
Man sieht hier eigentlich gar nichts, oder?
Es ist einfach nur Blöcke hingemacht, ohne dass man Inhalt sieht.
Es ist ja auch null miteinander verknüpft.
Vielleicht haben wir Glück.
und man kann wirklich eine ordentliche
Programmiersprache verwenden als das
mit Logo
ok, jetzt gibt es das ganze mal mit Logo
also mir
persönlich wäre eine ordentliche Programmiersprache
lieber als so
aber gut
genau, Expertenmodus
mit Quellcode, wäre schon cool
ansonsten habe ich halt die Frage
ich weiß halt nicht, wer sich die Mühe macht
da bin ich jetzt so ein bisschen
zwiegespalten, weil du hast
auf der einen Seite die
Hackerman-Leute, die sowas interessieren
die können aber in der Regel auch programmieren
es ist doch egal, ob Frostbite
C++ ist, wenn die sowas da
als Frontend basteln können, da können sie das
auch für Python
oder irgendwelche x-beliebige andere Sprache machen
da sind ja eh schon die Hackerman-Leute
die das interessiert, und die können in der Regel
auch, und selbst wenn es C++ wäre
wäre das Zeug ordentlich benannt, das ist alles in Ordnung
die können eh programmieren
und die anderen
interessiert es wahrscheinlich nicht
also ich bin echt skeptisch, inwieweit das
mehr Leute dazu bringt, was zu machen
kann man ändern, wie viel XP man kommt
also einen Cheat-Server
das wird nichts bringen
weil es unterschiedliche Spiele
also getrennte Module im Spiel sind
du hast Battlefield 20
42 All Out Warfare
das ist der Hauptspielmodus
dann hast du Battlefield Portal und du hast
Hazard Zone, das sind drei verschiedene
Module in dem Game, und ich gehe mal
davon aus, dass das eine mit dem anderen
nicht so wirklich interagieren kann
also wenn du hier XP hoch machst
falls das überhaupt geht, dann wird das
wahrscheinlich nicht auf das normale Battlefield auswirken
was ist das, Cross Progression?
das wäre aber, dann kannst du die XP nicht ändern
das wäre sonst alles andere
wäre äußerst merkwürdig
geh nochmal auf die Übersicht
zeig mal her
welche
äh
das da?
hier
earn XP and rank no matter where you play
das finde ich merkwürdig
ja dann gibt es gleich irgendwelche
easy Unlock Maps
das ist ja geil, überlegt euch
da kannst du ja voll bescheißen
also was heißt bescheißen?
bescheißen in Anführungszeichen
überlegt euch mal
das gibt einen Erfolg
50 Headshots mit der Sniper
dann machst du einfach eine Map
wo die Leute spawnen, Headshot only
sodass die Leute sich nicht bewegen oder so
nicht bewegen können
und du machst einfach die ganze Zeit
Headshot, Headshot, Headshot
easy
easy as fuck
oh leck das Stream
oh
Vodafone
Framedrops as fuck
alter
Vodafone
hör mal auf
ok, scheint wieder zu gehen
ne, leg nicht an dir, leg an Vodafone
ist schon vorbei
ja
ok, das mit Cross Progression habe ich nicht gesehen
aber das verwundert mich enorm
dass das Cross Progression ist
ohne Mist, das wundert mich echt enorm
aber eigentlich, überlegt euch mal
eigentlich ist es noch nicht mal gut
dass das Cross Progression ist
weil Cross Progression limitiert
das was sie an Features dort einbauen können
überlegt euch mal
sie wollten es wirklich zu einem Map Editor ausbauen
und noch mehr
vielleicht dass man sogar eigene Sachen
komplett neue
kreieren kann
das wäre, das ist, das ist, das ist
broken
für Cross Progression
wo steht das mit Cross Progression, hier unten
Shared Progression
meinen die damit nicht die Konsolen, naja
also wenn das, normalerweise würde ich sagen die meinen die Konsolen
aber wenn das explizit
auf dem Platz steht, wo es um Battlefield Portal geht
dann wird sich das auch auf Battlefield Portal ähm
beziehen
ich meine, es macht doch keinen Sinn
hier alles was für Battlefield Portal zu schreiben
und dann da unten äh Shared Progression
aber ja, es ist übrigens auch so
du kannst, zumindest haben sie es das letzte Mal gesagt
du kannst wohl Progression sharen zwischen Konsole und PC
wird es einen Server Browser geben
dazu haben sie sich bisher immer echt Hardcore gedrückt
da direkt drauf zu antworten
wir haben sie gefragt in der ersten FAQ
gab es keine direkte Antwort drauf
in der zweiten FAQ wurden sie gefragt
es gab keine direkte Antwort drauf
und bis jetzt hat man auch noch nichts gesehen
also sprich
Skill-Based Matchmaking
ist immer noch im Rennen
für das Game
und eins sage ich euch
gibt es Skill-Based Matchmaking, gibt es mich
in dem Spiel nicht
das werde ich mir nicht geben
For Cepha, das Cute Squad
das stimmt
aber mit dem Keyboard ist es nicht so gut, dass es so gut ist, dass es so gut ist, dass es so gut ist, dass es so gut ist, dass es so gut ist, dass es so gut ist, dass es so gut ist, dass es so gut ist
aber mit dem Cute Squad macht es auch keinen Bock
wenn du nur gegen Ultra-Tryhard-Leute 24-7 spielst
meinst du, die werden Battlelog-mäßig über eine Webseite gestalten?
ich vermute in-Game
was ich persönlich doof finde, weil ich Battlelog mag
ich vermute, dass sie es in-Game machen
Battlelog war eigentlich eine richtig gute Idee
so Menüs und Optionen und Sachen kannst du richtig gut im Browser machen
machen das brauchst du eigentlich gar nicht neu programmieren im spiel weiß gar nicht warum man
das nicht mehr macht man könnte es übrigens auch ohne probleme für konsolen anbieten heute hat
jeder ein smartphone macht eine battle log app und kannst scheuen für deine xbox war doch überhaupt
kein problem kann man doch machen was ist denn ein rsp ex-sorge ich bis spätestens seit diablo
immortal dass alle phones haben ui in game ist sowieso browser wahrscheinlich das stimmt schon
also es wird wahrscheinlich irgendwas html basiertes sein gehe ich auch mal voraus ja
aber trotzdem ist es über browser besser wenn du kompletten web service hast ja klar battle log war
nicht perfekt aber ich finde trotzdem besser als in game das zu machen ja leute ich muss mal was
essen
wie gesagt ich bin ja gerade erst angekommen und direkt ins stream wo ich hier vorhin eingeschaltet
habe ich werde es nicht herumschwitzen ich werde jetzt was essen gehen und dann sehen
wir uns im nächsten stream kurz und klar gehe ich heute bis dann war es gut